I was lucky in that I was studying
theater when I was in college University
and I got a job before I got out of
college it wasn't really a job it was
just an offer to work in classical
Repertory Theatre in which the pay was
going to be the professional experience
it went along with it and there was
there was a group of us we all went and
we knew we would be gone for four or
five months we knew we would have
something to do with either five or six
productions that were in repertory and
just the activity was enough to to
warrant going I had no had no
preconceived notions of anything I had
you know saved up enough money and to
barely survive and something would
happen and it just so happened that the
going actually was the most important
aspect of it because I went and after I
was there there was one particulars show
that needed a bigger cast than the
professionals could the pressure company
could could supply and because I was
there and I ended up getting actually
paid $50 a week which was the difference
between life and death so I I always
felt as though there was something on
the horizon that would come down the
pike that would get me through the next
the next few months but as far as you
know as far as you know bonafide break
goes the only things you go on is your
faith and and and your instinct and that
that window of cushion that you give you
that you would be able to give yourself
of you know enough money literally to
pay your rent I was married and I had a
kid at the time and just always needed
to have I said well I got 800 bucks in
the bank I think I'm good for about
another three months
I was operating on so much just instinct
and energy I would have perhaps told
myself to say if it's if you're right
now you're putting 60% energy into 40%
instinct reverse that make it 60%
instinct and 40% energy I was just loud
I was I was just fast and I sort of like
wood wood swamp the process with just
this kind of like blind accelerated pace
that uh that was the only that's the
only way I there's only speed I knew how
to operate and you know you learn how to
start examining the text in a different
way when you are sure enough that you
have the opportunity to work again
and by the time I had finished my third
year of that of that repertory company
and was in New York and was working in
some other medium I still had not
learned how to operate at a slower pace
of examining the text I was still just
trying to say hey I got this part
because I'm loud not fast and I'm funny
I just kept throwing myself into that so
I I could have learned probably a few
years earlier in order to take your time
and do the interior work yourself that
you need to do that you can do alone
just by just by studying the text before
that I would just learn the text and
then do it as opposed to really like
sort of planning out a motive attack
directors are made you know they're born
that way I every director I've worked
with has been completely different from
the others some directors talk to you a
lot some don't talk to you at all some
rehearse you literally with tape on the
floor and the text in your hands and
others won't even won't even put you
through any paces until you you show up
during the day I would say to any
director it's like cast well trust you
know you have to kick you have to trust
the cast that you have hired don't give
them the job if you don't think they're
going to you know you're not going to
have faith in what what they deliver
unto you and feel free to talk some of
the best direction I've ever got was can
you try something different you know
that that's a completely legitimate
direction to receive and sometimes
that's all that is required and I think
a directive other than that man just
plan the shot so you know so you'll get
your shots be organized quite frankly be
organized
in the beginning I was just thrilled to
know that someone was asking me to be in
a movie and I thought that was all that
was required and as long as they keep
asking everything everything will fall
fall into place mmm and I think I had to
become dissatisfied with my own process
you know five or six movies in where I
was feeling that that I was not I was
not bringing I was not bringing to the
work anything other than that anything
other than that instinct and that's when
I realized that you know okay I'm part
of me got older and I think even if
you're as old as 29 you you have a
different set of chops and perspective
you have a different believe it or not
wisdom that you did when you were 24 and
I think about every five years I went
through some sort of process of
reexamining where I was in life you know
as a man as well as an actor and
thinking like guess what I'm 36 now and
there's a whole world of movies that I
can't make it anymore because I can no
longer I don't want to play the young
man who's trying to figure out life I
want to play a man of bitter compromise
I want to play somebody who's who's been
through something so it's a never-ending
process I think of examining where you
are in life as a human being and then
transposing that so it's going to be
reflected in your work somehow
you